let's hear it so long kitchen
it's 5:00 p.m. on a Wednesday and
Virginia Beach and I'm stuck in
rush-hour traffic
you just started to value in humanity
many cars
[Applause]
prints one thing about some areas of
bread and whole time spending is
complaining about any trays
[Applause]
I have a lot of confidence right now
this matter I respect you so much and
this dude was like dude when people walk
on escalators this because it's a really
funny guy he comes all the way from
Queens New York and flips in a van like
a hipster
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys gonna be here it's a date
a woman was really into yoga and choke
sex and I was like do you enjoy
breathing or not may I remind you
millennial
these days this is sanded on city trains
at night my dick on sticky Black Panther
movie because they gave black children
in a hero they could finally woke up two
and not just someone like Martin Luther
King jr. Malcolm X or Harriet Tubman or
Rosa Parks or Thurgood Marshall
detective Jackie Robinson Willie Mays no
there's a fake person that just like you
can
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the sexually attractive to me and it's
really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh